let's jump from here and talk about the
evidence tampering
oh yeah yeah check this story out this
will blow your mind
saint louis prosecutor ordered crime lab
to reassemble patricia mccloskey's gun
assistant circuit attorney chris
hinckley stated in charging documents
the gun was readable readily capable of
lethal use
the only problem oh man i need my trump
button wrong wrong wrong
wrong excuse me wrong wrong we
definitely got to get those boxes
it's coming it'll be here soon it
actually should have been here it could
it could it could be actually it might
probably is here actually oh yeah i'll
have to take it for it yeah
i'll look for it tomorrow so for those
that aren't familiar because
you live under a rock there there's a
couple of people
they're married and a bunch of black
lives matter
people i don't know what whatever you
want to call them what do you want to
call them i don't know it's not a
protest when you break on a private
property and destroy property we need a
new word
where it's not a protester it's not a
rioter
but it's like it could go either way
really like you know what i mean it's
like right the middle line between
a protester and a writer because that's
kind of what it feels like yeah the
issue is when you say riot you imagine
people running around screaming smashing
windows
right when you say protester you imagine
a bunch of like hippies with like
sunflowers dancing and saying like peace
and love
yeah yeah really the problem is is there
are black lives matter protesters
that are only wanting to protest
peacefully and it's like
i see that but then there's these people
that hijack it
and steer it and and make people whip up
the emotions and
and you know start violence listen man i
i got
i gotta take over if there's a dude and
he's like hey everybody come with me
we're gonna go protest
wealth inequality and they go yay and
then he leads them into a bank and goes
everybody hit the deck bang bang bang
and they go
yay you're all bank robbers now yeah
like you can't just be like i didn't
know i was a peaceful protester that's
that's really good that's
that's funny you'll get charged yeah oh
here's all these words oh look at all
these these these
what is this angry mob yeah angry mob
assemblers some assembly please yeah
that's good i think i think mob is is is
good
it's an angry mob that's good yeah
that's true yeah because
an angry mob might not be doing anything
violent
they could just be angry and mobbing
yeah and this was like
it's so they entered private property
and at some point someone broke the gate
we don't know
it wasn't before because it's actually
video where you see them open the gate
everyone walks in but it was private
property
i read that thread i got that thread
from eric schmidt yep uh
according to the ag the moment they
walked into the private property he
could have just started blasting yeah
he could have gone full danny devito bam
bam bam bam bam bam bam bam her missouri
law
this castle doctrine uh doctrine state
like they could have shot all of them
yeah just and been like get off my
property no you are
you're coming closer to me dude boom
boom boom boom no no not it's it's worse
it's like better than i think it works
different it's more than that
according to the ag you can you can use
lethal force to prevent
imminent uh uh threats to yourself or
something or like you know uh
danger to yourself yeah as soon as they
enter your property
they went into a private community yep
the guy was on his porch he could have
went like
private property bang bang anyway anyway
he didn't do that
nope he did not do that but they came
and they took
patricia mccloskey's handgun she was the
one waving the
the pistol at everybody yeah turns out
it was inoperable
here's what they say the gun patricia
mccloskey waved at protesters was
inoperable
when it arrived at the saint louis
police crime lab but a member of the
circuit attorney kim gardner's staff
ordered crime lab experts to disassemble
and reassemble it
and wrote that it was quote readily
capable of lethal use in charging
documents filed monday
five on your side has learned good local
journalism you guys
rock this is what journalism is yes you
look at the documents we uncovered
evidence tampering from the state boom
boom
that's that's speaking truth to power
right there yes it is
in missouri police and prosecutors must
prove that a weapon is readily capable
of lethal use when it is used in the
type of crime in which the mccloskeys
have been charged
assistant circuit attorney chris
hinckley ordered crime lab staff members
to field strip the handgun
and found it had been assembled
incorrectly specifically the firing pin
spring was put in front of the firing
pin
which was backward and made the gun
incapable of firing according to
documents obtained by five on your side
firearms experts then put the gun back
together in the correct order and test
fired it finding that it worked
according to the documents patricia
mccloskey and her husband have said the
handgun she waved at protesters was
inoperable
because they had used it as a prop
during a lawsuit they once filed
against a gun manufacturer in order to
bring in uh bring it into a courtroom
they made it inoperable so they knew it
have you ever seen the movie
shooter yeah with with um awesome what's
that what's the mark wahlberg mark
wahlberg
great movie great movie in the end he
walks into the hearing with like
the feds and they have the the rifle on
the table
do you trust me with your life you gotta
speak in the microphone hold on
give me the room the room shot there we
go okay do you trust me with your life
tim
yes i do all right
so it's uh um michael michael pina i
think is his name is that his name the
actor yeah he's great too mark wahlberg
walks in
and he pulls a bullet out and he puts it
in the gun and he picks it up and he
aims at the dude he says do you trust me
with your life and he goes yes
and then when he pulls the trigger
nothing happens right and then he puts
it down and he says that he's removed
the firing or he he
removes he removes the firing pin and on
all of his guns switched them
no no that he trust me i've seen it i'm
my my understanding is that he switched
them so that you couldn't tell with
unless you had a micrometer
okay he said a normal person would see
the firing pin and think it would work
but it's off you need a micrometer to
tell ah
something like that some some really uh
yeah
yeah
you may be right so it is to say that
but you guys you guys might know because
i i remember something like that now i
got to see that movie again i really do
like that movie
it's a good one yeah when he goes and
gets revenge afterwards yep
anyway anyway i'm reminded of that when
they're like we used the gun as a prop
we knew it didn't work and then they s
they tampered with evidence to make it
work look at this thing
that blows me away look they're doing
how dirty this is seriously it's
political
yeah they're trying to make an example
morality policing
yes in the dirtiest way look at this
their attorney joel schwartz confirmed
to five on your side the mccloskeys
intentionally misplaced the firing pin
on the gun
and that it was in that condition when
patricia mccloskey waved at protesters
and turned it into their former attorney
quote it's disheartening to learn that a
law enforcement agency altered evidence
in order to prosecute an innocent member
of the community
a spokeswoman for garner says we can't
comment on a pending case
right and and then we're even finding
out that
they had every right to shoot these
people as per
missouri law so they didn't want that
they didn't want to shoot anybody
missouri castle doctrine yeah it's
actually kind of scary that's the castle
talk to you
it is it is the strongest of all of the
states actually according to the a.g
that's right yeah that's what it says so
i'm reminded of that episode of the
simpsons
where homer is told that if someone i
don't know the simpsons aren't in any
definable state but he's like if someone
comes into your property you can kill
them and he goes hmm
hey flanders well it doesn't work if you
invite him ah
and then he's like get out of here but
that's part of what it reminds me of
like
the strength so so i've got this this
twitter thread checks out there is a
springfield missouri just for the record
yes i know it's probably springfield
like probably five in one state yeah i
know
he says st louis prosecutor kim gardner
is engaged in a political
prosecution i entered the case seeking a
dismissal as a.g.i have a duty to
protect the fundamental rights of all
missourians including the right to keep
and bear arms in self-defense
of one's person and home a thread now
he issued this statement before the news
came out from five on your side which
was updated today came out in the
afternoon on the 21st a day later
yeah i'd like to see what he has to say
now oh yeah i believe
that the who whoever ordered this they
should all be criminally prosecuted
for conspiracy civil rights violations
josh hawley announced he wants a doj
investigation into the violation of
their rights
bring it on lock them up boom i agree
100
let's do this this this threat dirty
yeah dude
this this thread from eric schmidt is
fascinating he basically says 8 million
times
that this is a chilling effect on the
residents of missouri
that if you even consider protecting
yourself you may be coming
committing a crime and no one should
think that people need to
need to know for sure that if you come
on my property i can act as i need to to
defend it
and i don't have to risk being scared
that i've committed a crime hold on
there's there's actually something in
here that i that i caught
the reason why this i would like to to
find it but
he he says the the reason this state the
castle doctrine is so strong
is for the black community they put that
in there because
they they didn't they wanted people of
minorities to be able to defend
themselves
back in the day when it is oh you got it
the landmark heller decision mentions
its importance for anti-slavery
advocates and post-civil war firearms
for self-defense was often the only way
black citizens could protect themselves
from mob violence
wow that's yeah thank you yeah this is
why they're they're uh look at this it
also says
the right was explicitly in missouri's
first constitution of 1820 stating
quote the right to bear arms in defense
of themselves
and of the state cannot be questioned
cannot be questioned
it's not even look look the second
amendment of the united states be at the
left arguing well it says well-regulated
militia okay we'll stop you right there
because in missouri it says the right to
defend yourself
period yep they have a right to have
these weapons period yep
now check this out i want to go down to
the actual uh the statute he mentions
section 56.031 specifically authorizes
missouri citizens and homeowner
to protect themselves from illegal
invasions and intrusions into their home
and private property
it establishes three principles one
missourians may defend themselves and
others using physical force including
firearms
to deter the imminent use of unlawful
force by another person
unlawful force by another person
imminent meaning the moment you walk on
the private property they can say i feel
threatened
bang and not only that they were saying
that room i'm going to shower in
i'm going to sleep in that room it's
like well i'll
read through i read through what they
were saying about it it's like pretty
interesting you know what you know i
don't mention that
because there's no video the mccloskey
say that's what happened right right
right and as soon as you bring that up
the left is going to be like how do you
know they said that
okay then we won't bring it up at all
sure the moment they stepped on private
property
the mccloskeys had every right to defend
themselves as per
missouri law listen if you go in front
of a jury
a real reasonable jury of your peers and
say look at all of the riots and
vandalism and looting and murder
the dozen plus people had already been
killed do you think it's fair to say we
had reasonable fear of harm
absolutely definitely 100 did we have an
operable handgun
no did they tamper with it to try and
make you think we did
yes this stinks all the way oh like
check it out there's more though he says
two missourians may use deadly force
against a person who unlawfully
enters or attempts to enter private
property
that's the crazy part yeah they could be
trying to like about to step on your
grass like don't do it
if you raise that foot bang yep now of
course i'm being
a bit i'm exaggerating yeah but if
someone's at your door
and they're trying to open it you can
shoot them and kill them in missouri
you can be like you're trying to enter
my property bang bye-bye
yeah that's that's that's nuts three
missourians have no duty to retreat from
their own residence or property when
threatened by an unlawful intruder
further the castle doctrine specifically
shields missourians who act in valid
self-defense
from prosecution for unlawful use of a
weapon by exhibiting a weapon in angry
or threatening matter under five seven
one o three o
one uh parentheses four in fact
57.030.5 states it shall not apply to
persons
who are engaged in a lawful act of
defense pursuant to section 563.031
they can't even charge them with this
nope the law specifically states if they
are acting in any way on their property
this law shall not apply yet they did it
anyway and
and they altered the evidence to go
after them yep it's political
do you know what's going on in seattle
and in oakland and poor uh
and yeah seattle and oakland the the far
left is showing up to politicians houses
who aren't bending to their will so in
seattle
the council said we're gonna defund the
police except for like two or three
people okay so what happened
the far left showed their houses and
vandalized it in oakland they went to
the mayor's house and vandalized it yep
saw that i said it man they're gonna
start coming to your house
now now right now people are saying yeah
but they're just
tagging it up and vandalizing stuff
right
here's what happens next they went to
tucker's house i think last year
we're banging on the door tucker says
they broke it they claimed they didn't
i'm sure there's probably some damage
and they're trying to say no and tucker
might be trying to act like it's more
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna assert
anything that's what was said
his wife was hiding in the closet she
called 9-1-1 cassandra fairbanks
they showed up to her house in the wee
hours of the morning and they started
firing fireworks
and according to sandra some active
gunfire
she called the police they found the
commercial mortar launching stuff the
neighbors confirmed it
was it was happening and they've done it
before so why would i
act like it didn't happen they went to
the mayor of oakland's house and they
did the same thing with fireworks
it's happening they're going to your
house what happens next is it takes one
person
while this is all going on to run up and
kick the door now the door's busted in
then people are standing around the
house being on the windows and one
person peeks in the door and looks
inside
and then someone sees that and they
think hey they're going in they push in
this is how mob mentality works one
person will do one little thing
and then someone else will do one little
thing above it and then everyone adds a
little bit to the avalanche
and before you know it they come to your
house someone throws a brick breaking
the window
someone runs up and pops it open runs
away someone else goes up to the door
and looks inside and throws a smoke bomb
or a mortar
then everyone sees people running to the
door and they all run inside
the next thing you know you're being
dragged out and beaten in the street
and you and and people don't believe me
they didn't believe me when i said this
was going to happen
when i mentioned that the violence is
going to escalate regular people are
going to get involved they're going to
show up to your house
people were like no they're not it's not
coming to the suburbs
and then it did and now they went to
this family's home this is where the
morality policing kicks in
and this the mccloskeys did literally
nothing wrong
they are defended according to the ag to
a ridiculous degree
and the law explicitly states as he
noted the law doesn't apply to people
who are acting in defense pursuant to
this
this this law 563.031 yet they
charged them anyway yep that's insane
well the good news is i guess the
mccloskeys are civil rights lawyers
right is that what
is it yeah they're lawyers they know
what they're doing so hopefully they go
nuclear oh yeah and i think they're
gonna have the support of
holly the ag and the governor yep and
president trump right
figuratively light them up figuratively
got to make sure you say figuratively i
want to see a tactical
legal nuke because this is this is
malicious prosecution
malicious they altered evidence
to me that is that look maybe i'm i'm
not a lawyer
yeah when i saw that like i was taken
back
like wow like they are straight up being
dirty
like they're changing they're they're
trying to get them
they're making an example of these two
to to
make sure that the rest of the citizens
know if you do this
we're gonna we can we can throw you in
prison
when they're they were well within their
rights to do
much more than they did built especially
when they
knew they knew those guns didn't fire
they knew they were just yep like stay
away from our house i don't know about
the rifle
but the handgun okay i want to see
what to whatever extent we can get some
real prosecution of these corrupt
individuals
absolutely eric schmidt points out all
these things i got to point out it shall
not apply to persons who are engaged in
a lawful act of defense pursuant to
section 563031
if that's true and maybe he's leaving
something out i doubt it he's the ag
we'll see how it plays out i want to see
criminal charges against
every single person involved i want to
see the police officers
who seized the rifle charged 100
those cops that decided they were going
to follow an unlawful or because let me
let me clarify
if these officers violated section
571030.5 which says that law shall not
apply
if they violated 563.031 which gives
them the right to self-defense by
firearm
the police illegally seized their
weapons that's true
just following orders is not an excuse
and on top of that
that sounds like a 2a violation too
because they broke no laws that's true
they broke no laws and the cops went and
did it anyway those cops need to be held
responsible period
we cannot everyone along the chain does
yeah every single person
there are i've seen so many videos of
these cops saying i refuse to enforce
that violation of our constitutional
rights
when when virginia was like we're going
to take your weapons away you got to
turn to men all these chefs were like
nope we're a sanctuary
you know yeah we'll deputize people
we're not letting you take your guns
in saint louis where according to the
a.g it's one of the it is the strongest
castle doctrine state
you have a right to bear arms in
self-defense period why would those
police go to their house and take the
gun away from them
just following orders sorry that's never
been an excuse for americans
never we we talk all day night about the
nuremberg trials it was a nuremberg
right that's what it's called
yeah the trial the nazis yeah we talk
all day and night about how following
orders is not an excuse
i'm not saying the guys lose their job
i'm not saying that they get locked up
i'm saying
there's got to be some accountability
for cops who
violate the law yep well and then
here how i'm going to read further into
this it says he says the highly
politicized prosecution of missouri
citizens for exercising their rights
to keep and bear arms in self-defense
may intimidate and
deter other missourians from exercising
their fundamental right
of self-defense this case reflects the
opposite of the state's constitutional
obligation
under article 1 section 23 to uphold
these rights
to keep and bear arms self-defense and
protect
against infringement and it says uh
2a shall not be infringed in fact this
political prosecution sends a powerful
and dangerous message
you exercise your right to keep and bear
arms at your own peril
if you do you may find yourself in
prison this case has a significant
uh significance that extends well beyond
the parties
he's right let me let me that's right
let me ask you a question um
if uh i don't know a a couple of people
are in their home
and a mob shows up yelling
and enters private property at some
point destroying this gate
and um there's a history of violence
associated with them
is it is it oppression and and uh uh
you know fascism when you say hey get
out of here you're threatening my
property.
okay if if a bunch of these you know far
left extremists
show up to a federal courthouse lobbying
commercial grade fireworks
and fire bombs and whatever at a federal
courthouse is that is that impression
nope it's it's wait wait no okay you had
two questions so i wanted to answer them
so now we'll carry it on
if in response to the extremists law
enforcement come out
and say disperse you're engaged in an
illegal activity
is that oppression nope now if the
if if the uh district attorney i believe
the district attorney or
kim gardner whatever position is
files charges in violation of the law
and the crime lab
tampers with evidence to manipulate it
to falsely frame a couple of people who
are legally defending their property is
that oppression
yes yes absolutely and there we go
i found the oppression so we found it we
figured it out congratulations everyone
we did it we found out where the fascism
is it is
oh oh my this is well this is strange i
didn't expect this
the the the leftists it's coming from
the leftists are tampering with evidence
to falsely frame people who are legally
within their rights
well this can't be they're the ones
fighting fascism yep they were called
antifa i thought that meant anti-fascism
they they can't be
the bad guys it's in their name whatever
does it mean
we've got some strange going ons here
this this certainly doesn't make sense
wait a minute
could it be that the people claiming to
oppose fascism actually don't
whoa and this is the big point i brought
up with the clearing of the jazz
bring it all back together with trump
with the the deployment of operation
legend with law enforcement
they say they want to defund police they
want to defund the police
except in uh you know st louis where
we're falsely prosecuting to innocent
people and tampering with evidence to
you know put him in prison
they want to end these these malicious
jailings of innocent people well except
in st louis where we're going to tamper
with evidence to ensure we can
lock up our ideological opponents does
that mean they don't want to defund the
police
kind of they want to get rid of the
police now so that no one stands in
their way
they just want the power exactly when
given the opportunity
they will falsely accuse you frame you
and tamper with the evidence to make
sure they win
now we can be sitting here saying it's a
good thing we have an ag and
the governor and we we won't always
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm if you want to
catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode